et quand vous parlez de la maison
blanche c'est bien connu on a eu une
idée pour vous présenter inspiration
s'il était président oui ou non vous une
erreur passée n'arrivera jamais tout
what a régné oui régner sur toutes les
fêtes de la tomate
[Applaudissements]
je dois compte tenu des propos d'une
miss alors pendant son règne
je suis miss france à la villa c'est
comme que brad bah oui mais non sera
toujours miss france la dame au coeur de
tous les gens que tu vois de samedi soir
mais je vois s'il était président des
états unis les paparazzis seraient
considérés comme de vrais photographe et
artiste c'est pas le cas sébastien
valide
à noter que depuis que je vis le petit
script baroudeur ça attire les meufs
quelle que soit l'heure de la journée
même à ma vue top est la petite baisse
qui fait bien genre hier par travail
abbaoui est un guerrier tome et des
boîtes de nuit si elle était présidente
des états unis il n'y aurait jamais eu
d'affaires monica lewinsky compris
[Applaudissements]
ces gars là je suis pas sûr qu'avec le
président il aurait fumé avec toi mais
n'a même pas ce qu'il fait attention
maintenant écolo tout un jeu pas comment
je m'en sors s'il était président des
états unis avoir un micro pénis tueur
est considéré comme une cause nationale
[Applaudissements]
ne me regarde taxerait tu peux tu peux
aller en régie à la pause
emilie 1 et nourdine qui sont des
producteurs qui font des blagues là
dessus parce que malheureusement et ont
croisé dans les loges s'agit si elle
était bien à dire tellement ces on est
franchement au niveau de frein à oui
c'est dans leur ai dit oui c'est vrai
ces petits comme base pour ta gouverne
mesure que même ça commence à 4 cm au
repos donc si tu as 4 1 je pense que
vous avez un problème on dit ce moment
c'est celui qui est quoi êtes-vous ne
parlait que de ça mais c'est pas moi le
problème
ou alors en plus tu atteints de cécité
et la savait deux problèmes en même
temps à l'hélice a cité les dans le chic
si elle était président des états unis
elle passerait tout c'est samedi soir
ah non c'est pas top balmer si elles
étaient présentes des états unis le
seraient elles seraient en guerre contre
tout le monde
évidemment c'est myriam palumbo
[Applaudissements]
s'il était président des états unis elle
passerait tout c'est samedi soir à
draguer et à l'otan pour moi on me dit
dans l'oreillette que c'est déjà fait
part de son souhait de voir se terminer
par une excuse chose qui a régné hier
soir elle était dehors j'ai reçu des
photos du terrien qui a gagné il m'a 8
mai toutes les touts les salles us
holdings et des vidéos d'elle hier soir
dans la rue dans la rue les gens vont
envoyer des vidéos non moi je dis on
était jeudi normal mais j'attendais
tranquillement combien de me chercher
ouais et je reçois une vidéo de moi à
l'instant même de seb
cela dit je peux me permettre j'ai
vraiment je sais que j'aime toutes les
professions je dénigre personne mais si
tu attends vraiment avenue foch comme ça
à la règle j'attends qu'on vienne le
chercher c'est combien mais quoi je
viendrai tant décrié
ban a tenu quand même la tenue vidéo
était ambiguë jamais dollar est tombé
s'il était président des états unis il
obligerait tout le monde à savoir lire
et écrire et donc magali berda qui
traînent pis s'il était président des
états unis il souhaite comme donald
trump avait dirais que des conneries et
freine couleurs ben oui être avec nous
et enfin s'il était président des états
unis nabila serai ministre de la culture
[Applaudissements]